a reviewer is never late no is he early
he reveals precisely when he means to
least that's what I'm gonna tell myself
when I throw up a review four months
after a game came out Grand Theft Auto V
so Grand Theft Auto 5 is the newest
Grand Theft Auto game from rockstar it's
an open-world game to an insane degree
who actually plays three main characters
and you see their story arcs converge
and ultimately they collaborate they do
crime and you can do crime individually
with these criminals and you pretty much
screw over the biggest prettiest on game
city ever did I mention this game's big
cuz it's big I'm gonna point out what I
liked in this game first of all like I
said it's a huge city you can explore to
your heart's content there's a lot to
see and there's a lot to do some of its
pretty [ __ ] pointless and some of its
pretty cool to do I like the fact that
these cars don't drive like dog ass like
the ones in GTA 4 did I like the fact
that you can play the stock market in
the game after I got Trevor and blasted
all my money on an airplane bunker that
I never went back to I was like I need
to find a way to make money okay there
is a virtual stock market in the game
every company has a rival company when
you play as Franklin you usually do
things that screw over one company so
before you do that mission have your
guys dump all their money in the rival
company and that stock will go up then
you pull the money now you have more
money pretty standard GTA formula you're
a criminal you build your empire you do
crime you screw over people if you're
not killing them they're gonna end the
situation very unhappy my favorite
character of the three I gotta say was
Franklin I felt the game got a lot
better than it was when Trevor came on
board Trevor's completely insane it's
always fun to see an insane person doing
insane things so I had fun with Trevor
my least favorite Michael I didn't care
about his family problems I didn't give
a [ __ ] about his [ __ ] but the bummer is
even with Franklin and Trevor I'm not
gonna walk away from this game going
yeah they were characters I'm gonna
remember forever prolly these characters
have dug into my soul it's not like
they're Joel and Ellie or anything it's
not like they're booker dewitt getting
all this revelation where you're like
you walk away from the game going holy
now they're GTA characters and in the
end they don't matter as much as you
want them to and that is one of the big
bummers of this game this game is huge
its enormous in quantity but you know
the old phrase there's a difference
between quantity and quality yeah you
remember that phrase this is one of the
biggest games I've ever played but it
has so many things going on in it then
it lacks focus take the Arkham games
Arkham origins Arkham City feels like
open-world
it is open-world in the sense that you
can go across the skyline you can go
anywhere on the surface but the game
gives you focus it's like oh I'm Batman
I'm going after these criminals do you
feel like you're always in mode like all
right Batman has a point he has to do
this thing GTA 5 I felt like I was three
guys just going around doing random
crime because that's what GTA 5 is and
in that it comes down to personal
preference if you like a game that's
that open where you can do anything like
golf GTA 5 is your cup of tea but if GTA
5 is your thing then you already have
GTA 5 and I'm not telling you anything
you don't already know the game does
have cool missions for sure and when
your main characters team up and they do
the big [ __ ] you're like that's awesome
but the game has it's frustrating
missions where you're like sweet you
started me out right next to a bunch of
cops and you gave me a three star wanted
rating art I'm gonna get away from them
no shot because the cops are psychic in
this game so many times I was running
from the cops no cops saw me I got into
another car started driving the cops
were like there he is I don't know that
but there he is
and then they ram into you and you're
like how did you know that was me
luckily they gave you that one option
where you can push square and skip a
mission when you fail it three times
which is a slippery slope like anything
you do it once you're like oh my Saul I
didn't want to do that I feel like such
a [ __ ] then the next time something
here at a2 you're like well I already
did it once I might as well do it again
you got to be careful not to spam it
because then it compromises the entire
experience some of the missions in this
game I was like why am I doing this at a
point when I was stacking cargo boxes
with a crane on two trucks I looked at
my friend and I was like it's baffling
the goosebumps that this 9.5 at a
10-game is giving me right now I swear
he just laughed he's like yeah I
understand
he loves gta5 but he understands you
can't just breezed over that you could
have had the character to be like oh
yeah we stacked the boxes and [ __ ]
alright now let's go do this thing this
thing that's actually fun GTA 5 has so
many elements in it that it doesn't
actually excel at anything bear with me
on this it has a lot of characters so
none of the characters really stand out
there's so many cars and driving
elements in it that it's not the best
driving game ever you can fly but it's
not the best flying game ever it's not
the best third-person action shooter
game ever it's not as good as uncharted
2 you can even golf in the game it's not
the best golf game over grand theft auto
5 has a lot of elements you can do in it
but really are they necessary they're
there for the sake of being there so you
know that you could do it but at no
point have I ever been playing a crime
game or an action game you've been like
I mean you know what would really set
this game over the top is if I could
golf if I could golf I'd like the game
but since I can't no thank you
the bummer is there are people I haven't
reviewed the game but they're on blogs
and chat and they're like I'm not
enjoying GTA 5 as much as I should be
which bummed me out because at that
point people are like there's something
wrong with me I don't like GTA 5 now
there's nothing wrong with you the game
is not as good as you heard it should be
simple as that I don't mean to [ __ ] on
the game GTA 5 is still enjoyable sure
I'm just saying is it as good as the
last of us or BioShock Infinite
not remotely there's a lot to do there's
a lot to play with in GTA 5 and if you
want to do everything in the game it's
going to last you months upon months
upon months but I personally personal
preference because that's what reviews
are well take a three-hour game that
makes me go holy [ __ ] that was epic that
a 50 hour game that makes me go why am I
playing this game and why don't I like
it as much as I think I should in the
end I know it feels like I [ __ ] on this
game more than I wanted to I will
actually say GTA 5 is worth buying at
sale price I paid 60 bucks for an idiot
aced me made 20 or 30 bucks for it I'd
be like oh cool look at all this [ __ ] I
feel like this is gonna be classic like
all people who have been like Jeremy
root for you GTA 5 now we're gonna watch
this and then be like right by review it
I meant review it and give it a positive
review that's what I wanted to see can
you redo your review please no this is
my review this is what you get it's a
GTA 5 have you played it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you